drama what drama blac chyna steps out in  a pair of daisy dukes looking casual and  carefree she's known for not like given  to  [Music]  the 29 year old was spotted out and  about rocking a pair of short shorts and  a smile on Thursday  despite her current legal battle with  ex-fiance Rob Kardashian on Monday a  judge granted Chyna a temporary  restraining order against the reality  star I would like to first and foremost  thank the judge for granting me this  restraining order to protect me and I'm  just gonna get back to co-parenting  dreams on Thursday Chyna who has a four  year old son king with ex Tyga and eight  month old daughter dream with Rob's  beamed with pride as she snuggled up to  her little girl on snapchat and it  appears she's taking out her stress in  the gym I'm really like proud of like  what I've done so far the model shared a  flurry of workout videos on snapchat  Thursday and we are hashtag impressed  thank you